what's exciting today in
entrepreneurship is at least at least
three things first this explosion of
women going in into the entrepreneurial
field if you will are onto the
entrepreneurial ocean and bravely sail
it bravely sailing forth to create their
own businesses in their own products and
we're not I'm not talking just about
women you know with with with rich
education and many many you know sort of
economic assets I'm talking about women
at all points along the social spectrum
who are you know building beauty shops
setting up setting up small schools for
their kids opening up new
telecommunications ventures creating a
beauty company to sell to a larger
beauty corporation women doing
astounding things all over the map for a
variety of reasons it's not the least of
which is being their own boss and having
control of their time but women are now
starting in this country more businesses
than men by some measure and that's
interesting and exciting and different
than in the past
secondly because of what's happened to
the capital markets because of the
extraordinary expansion in financial
instruments and in kind and in number
and in sources of funding you now have
entrepreneurs from all kinds of pockets
of society that now have a chance to get
the cash which is the oxygen right of
any idea any business in its first few
you know months or years in the garage
to get the oxygen and to try to try and
bring their idea out of the ether so you
now have pockets of entrepreneurship you
know all over the world being you know
being purposefully if you will purposely
enabled and stimulated and so we see
young men in the inner city starting
businesses we see entrepreneurs in Latin
America in the Latin American
countryside starting businesses we see
graduate from the Harvard Business
School starting businesses as soon as
they get their diploma that the
flowering so broadly of entrepreneurship
among so many different people because
they can find the money is really
important and really interesting and I
think thirdly
you know if you look at if you look at
the cycles of history where you look at
the great religious traditions there
isn't all of them you know at oohing and
froing or going and coming back being at
this point and coming round again in an
undetermined amount of time to that
point again there's a wonderful line in
TS Eliot's Four Quartets that says I
shall not cease from exploration and the
end of all my exploration will be to
arrive where I started and to know the
place for the first time and we are in a
moment in history when when as as this
country was at the end of the nineteenth
century or Britain was in the middle of
the eighteenth century when we are
coming back to an economy that will be
absolutely powered by entrepreneurial
activity
not only in terms of job creation not
only in terms of invention and
innovation but also in terms of the kind
of assets those entrepreneurs will
control and the kind of market share
they will enjoy and that's very obvious
in the United States and it's very
obvious in China and I think it's in
India and I think it's going to be more
obvious in other parts of the world
including the Middle East over the
coming 20 or 25 years